[Music]
yes it's monday morning
monday morning january 3rd
this is officially the first
episode of the shop show aka below the
bell aka big brown breakdown
but we're not it's the first shop show
it's the same show i've been doing for
years and years now it's just uh
rebranded man because your boy is on his
own your boy is on his own mr
independent
um yeah shout out to showtime thanks for
all the years
but now we're riding man now we're
riding unfiltered unedited we're not
gonna play any of those games you're
eating your boy here raw
raw dog
raw dog here we are um yeah man
super excited really so this is episode
267 chin 267 267 if you count the below
the belts with show time we're not
starting with number one because it's
the same show but really if you even go
back further with the big brown
breakdowns this is 267
it's probably episode 300 something if
you include the include the big brown
breakdowns
because once i'm once uh once a week
so i guess firing kid around episode 700
something but really that's over a
thousand if you include the fox sports
and the ones brian i
initially did out of his garage that's
over a thousand thinking on the stings
on what king's thing's on
almost 200 yeah
i'm gonna just double check real quick
last game this thing was
years ago um was
so if you scroll down though
that they're on one fifth was it 150
what hold on let me look let me just
real quick
it's not going to say on there
go back gin
and then if you go to the christmas one
just scroll over it says the number
right to the there 153 so 150 so 154
once a week not bad man
not bad at all oh duh best of cats yeah
that's why i'm saying that yeah that's
what i was trying to get i got you so
really that's 154 the best of but
it's not a new episode so i'm with you
we're on 153 i get what you're doing
there nikki d nikki boy nikki boy i
guess nikki d works his name's nick
david yeah
that works man how was your new year's
june it's good just chill
straight home stay up to midnight
yeah and then you know everyone's
getting sick right now dude like
everybody everybody yeah which i think
is a good thing shows were at the end of
the pandemic but also not a doctor so so
we just facetimed all our friends
and took shots together oh wow getting
together yeah just to be safe
sure that's fair hey do what you want
man do what you want we brought the new
years in uh i think for the third or
fourth year in the row on stage
and so we're in dania florida brand new
club beautiful club out there
and uh
they gave us bottles of uh that's me and
david there dana me and my boy david
uh and he actually has a um
he has a show dropping on a thick boy
called flatline with david lucas where
if you've ever followed david on
instagram if you're not he's a great
follower but if you ever follow david he
does a thing where people
go instagram live and they get roasted
he goes through a million you know tons
of people roast them i was like dude
this is a show
so we're launching it i think is it next
week
so next week it's it's sometime in
january on think boy channel it's called
flat line with dave lucas and hope he'll
do it on his end but um it's uh
fans are gonna call him to get roasted
and he is a straight
savage
we he's one of the few comics where we
sit in the back hoping somebody yells
something out so he lights him up but uh
yeah he's the gift of uh the roasting
the roast master himself obviously jeff
ross with roastmaster but david is right
there he is a monster
so his show will launch on thick boy
this month which we're looking forward
to
i bought that shirt i like i i dressed
like don chula in the 70s when i was on
stage um but yeah so we brought the new
years in and they gave us uh champagne
but the way they do it now they they
give you champagne and uh it's not the
bottle i'm sure they still make those
about you know the balls you gotta like
take a knife and hit the corkscrew and
it goes
flying
yeah they didn't want that so these ones
you turn they kind of just like pop off
but then we start celebrating like it
was goddamn like we want to f1 race and
so we
someone put what that knee do
baby and someone said meet me at acl
surgery baby
dude
so me and uh david had the bottles and
we're shaking it that's his girl in the
back there but we're shaking it and
spraying each other and spraying the
fans
and then uh i don't want to spray his
girl and i see justin just knows has a
fly outfit on and i know how expensive
it was so i don't want to ruin his
clothes so i'm like spraying just or
trying to avoid people but it's going
all over the floor and for whatever
reason justin decided to run it's at
just an uncut but uh he decided to run
he ate all the [ __ ] he ate so this video
doesn't do it justice he fight he hit
the ground so goddamn hard he [ __ ] up
all the plants the random cuff coffee
cup came flying out and broke weak david
was it straight up in tears laughing so
goddamn hard hit that video
david i'm talking laughed for probably
30 minutes like tears coming out of his
eyes just nate shits it's like a slow
[ __ ] fall too oh dude but it was so loud
like that video i don't know who took
that video that's awesome he defended
but i i decided to go inside because i
was spraying the thing and there's just
some bro in the front row going like
this
okay i don't want to bring in my new
years with this visual so i went back uh
to the green room
yeah man danny was dope danny was really
cool here's me and my bro at the beach
chappelle was actually there but he
didn't want to get in the water hip
count
brothers see here see here's the thing
here's the thing so i put so uh i said
the florida splash bros random man of
war jellyfish aka satan bubble of the
sea go over to the mana war so this
thing's chilling there
so you can't see but the tentacles are
under the sand and they go far and i
told my my brother was like it's just a
jellyfish i'm like that's a man of
so we looked it up and it is a man of
war and then the most painful jellyfish
but here's the problem not the problem
the thing with social media so this guy
marquez 25 216 go but relax the [ __ ]
blue bottle
laughing emoji not even a top 10 of
ouchy things in australian waters yeah
dude because australia has tons of [ __ ]
that can kill you but when we're
chilling the fort lauderdale that bath
water of an ocean and we run in a man
award we freak out we're not used to
that [ __ ] out here man and then i you
know i love animals so i wanted to save
it so i tried grabbing a seashell and
tossed him in the back in the ocean so
he didn't die because obviously he got
washed upon the shores
but there's all these kids playing and
he started heading straight for the kids
not you know he just goes with the tide
he started floating towards these
[ __ ] five and eight year olds so i
had to run over to the parents i guess
i'm out of war like how to get back in
the water i'm like i have no idea save
yourselves
but we looked it up
again i know australia's like whatever
dude that's like a [ __ ] you know bug
bite dude you look up how bad their
stings hurt and it is no
joke here's the thing this guy uh put uh
alien underscore p but you're supposed
to piss on it that is a urban myth
you're not supposed to be on it it
actually does nothing they say um you're
supposed to go back in the water
you're supposed to go back in the water
the salt water helps it
i don't know who invented the piss thing
i guess if you have nothing and you just
want to piss on your friend do it
but uh the the peeing on a jellyfish
thing i hate to tell everybody is an
urban myth it's not true in any facet i
learned about watching friends
friends yeah they do it on um
heartbreak kid
he hits his girl pisses on him he gets
stung by jellyfish they must [ __ ]
hurt though man
when they're colorful like this that to
me that's danger
dude i know my animals i knew that was
the man of war [ __ ] off the bat and
so i was saying that i'm like someone's
gonna [ __ ] step on that thing and all
we just sit there and watch it it
stressed me out
looks cool though
a little whiskey for the first episode
of the shop show man oh yeah a little
whiskey see behind me
uh i guess some of my
i don't say favorite whiskies
probably i respect proper 12 but not not
my top 70 whiskeys but uh what he did
with it what connor did with that thing
you gotta uh you can't hate on that so
you got proper 12 back there you got
rear stash which is my boy dustin
porre's uh it's good it's very yeah yeah
very very good and uh he just launched
that last friday yeah tiger thick
definitely the best out of the ones up
there and uh we just signed with a huge
distributor so that's in coming this
year actually this month it's gonna be
available all over the place
and then johnny drum from kentucky's
personal favorite and then up there i
want to highlight my uh
my favorite sneaker of the month so i'm
gonna switch it out every month but that
is the nike yeezy when kanye was with
nike and created shoes
and the issue with that is my boys from
suplex sent me that because i've been
looking for it for
around six years been trying to get that
shoe and uh i got it and uh prom is size
12. your boy was 13.
but i will scram my [ __ ] big toe in
there and because uh pain is uh fashion
so it's up there so i don't get an
ingrown toenail but every month i'll
switch that shoe out
yeah man this is it my boy brian johnson
built the set if you're looking for a
podcast set hit up my boy brian johnson
he builds all my sets king the sting
fighting the kid
shop show cowbest fight companion
chappelle's sets he builds every single
thing that you see
uh in thick boy's studio is all brian
johnson he's a brilliant brilliant man
beast and uh yeah he did that corolla
set when he coming set uh he did the set
for my special he he flew out to dallas
built the set at the s improv
news on that special very soon for you
guys i can't wait and uh
yeah brian's a beast brian is a beast uh
but let's get to the fight world man
what is happening in the fight world
well
as i always like to say they're edginess
they're taking a little break and
they're edginess with some fight nights
there's a fight night next week but
until then the ufc kind of stays they
lay low they lay low till you uh get
that pay-per-view and my god is it a
pay-per-view and we got a cowboys fight
campaign on thick boy channel youtube uh
cowbest fight companion with christa
stefano crystalia brian callan myself
for the big ass heavyweight titles on
the line francis angano cyril gone i
can't frickin wait man i can't remember
last time i was this excited for a fight
trying to think there's nothing like two
really really good heavyweights and i
think the thing uh the narrative on this
you know francis has been in a different
fight francis has been in a fight with
the ufc brass which is whenever you're
going to fight with ufc brass you're not
going to get the shine you deserve uh
take a page out of woodley's book you
take a page out of
like even the diaz is man look at the
diaz is who um you know
whenever you get into
uh
dispute with the ufc
they control the narrative unfortunately
and it's not like france says big pot
doesn't go on and rip off what's really
going on he'll do some interviews with
tmz or an outlet or markell his agent ca
who's a friend of mine he'll you know
he'll do some interviews but
those aren't going mainstream you know
what i'm saying so
the ufc controls the natives it's a bit
of a shame a bit of a shame because i
you know what francis is trying to do i
i love the
the message you know i think he's saying
hey pay me what i deserve
um you know he's obviously one of the
scariest
men mend ever enter the octagon and he
he wants you know he sees those paydays
from boxing which is different i i think
it's weird when guys reference boxing
but um
i don't know how it ends for him i
really don't can you name a guy who's
gone to battle with ufc and has won you
know what i'm saying that's ever really
really worked out for them
it's just tough man because with the
ufc's business model it's not like it is
back in the day where you know they
based in uh kind of
made their business plan off of
superstars where you want to buy the big
pay-per-views because that's how they
made their nut every month and stuff
like that
they're good now ma'am they're i don't
they're not in cruise control because
they're working their ass off but as far
as the business model they are in cruise
control because they're such a
mainstream sport now they're getting
mainstream sponsors they have the espn
deal where they have to provide whatever
is 40 between 40 and 50 flights a year
to them and those pay-per-views are also
on espn plus that you buy on there so
espn's covering the nutmen so they're
they're chilling they're in teslas and
they're in that cruise control and
driving around collecting cash so
i think now more so than ever fighters
have it very difficult
and i think uh that's surprising for a
lot of people because you'd think the
the bigger the names the more success
guys get the more power they have i
think ufc learned from conor mcgregor
they gave that guy too much power
and uh although they made a ton of money
i don't think they would change anything
but they're i don't think they're ever
gonna let another guy get as much power
as conor mcgregor has over the ufc i
think they learned their lesson and you
know he's made hundreds and hundreds of
millions dollars off them obviously
they've probably made more of him but um
i think they learned their lesson with
him but i don't know if we will get
another conor mcgregor um anytime soon
so
for francis it's tough man because you
look at it let's look at the two side of
things that he's trying to do
now when we get to the fight week we're
just gonna be talking about fight i'm
gonna talk about this other [ __ ] but
we have about two weeks to that fight so
let's talk about the business side with
francis yeah
put yourself in france gano's shoes
right heavyweight champ
um
you know beat beat stipe has some of the
greatest knockouts in ufc history uh
opened a new market for them um you look
at the champs you look at um
izzy you know who's uh african you look
at kamar usman who's african you look at
francis who's african there's obviously
a market there um you look at the the
gate of izzy versus whitaker's the
biggest gate of all time so there's
clearly a demand there in australia new
zealand africa and i think they'll start
tapping the resources into africa
um
so francis has definitely
kind of paved the way for that and also
izzy
but
you know so for francis he decided not
to sign a long-term contract right and
bank on himself which completely love
that's what your boy's doing here i've
put every dollar i had into thick boy
and hiring a staff and banking on the
team that i have um you know making this
thing a success and i think we're on the
right track
so i love francis for that but
you know when you when you talk about it
so
option a
re-sign with ufc
you re-sign with ufc it's gonna be a
six-fight deal uh most likely no less
than six fights you're gonna get more
money based off of if you're holding the
title you're gonna get pay-per-view
points and i would assume france's team
assume that he's gonna stay champ for
very for a very long time that being
said you look at francine's payouts when
he was champ when he did fight stipe
when he did fight you know derek lewis
and these other guys in overeem and he
definitely wasn't paid what he's worth
but
you know now in renegotiation i'm sure
they're gonna pay more but
he's seeing the money that and i think
is a good thing that jake paul is making
that uh uh wilder was making anthony
joshua a fury is making it's trouble
when you start looking at those those
boxes because ufc is a completely
different business model and you can run
some trouble with that so francis
instead of
saying
uh yeah i'll refi i'll resign with you
guys for six years be the face of the
heavyweight division uh get your foot in
the door into africa and be your guy
uh he said no i'm gonna bank on myself
again which i love
but i think as his business manager
if
if it's legacy
not re-signing with the ufc and banking
yourself can be a little dicey because
name someone who that has left the ufc
and has gotten more famous and has
gotten
bigger and received more endorsements
i'll wait because there's there's just
ufc is mma it just is i know a lot of
people don't want to hear this
if i was my previous employers they
would have edited this out
this is facts if you're not fighting in
the ufc you're just not considered the
best in the world
that's and that's not my thing that's
not chin's thing that's like casey's
thing that's just the way it is if
you're not playing the nfl you're not
considered the best quarterback in the
world you're not playing the nba not
considered the best point guard in the
world uh if you're not playing the
premier league or if you're not on the
on the olympic national team you're
considered the best [ __ ] whatever
goalie in the world you know what i'm
saying so the ufc sets the standards and
they have the biggest hype machine
behind them uh and have the deepest
divisions and there couldn't be
a tougher organization to become a
champion than the ufc these other
leagues can their champs compete with
the ufc champs
yeah i'm sure there's some guys could
probably beat some of our champs but i'm
saying from 1 to 50 if you start at 50
to make it to be the number one guy is
damn near impossible you have to walk
through [ __ ] fire like no other
organization in the world and that's why
any champion you see is considered the
very best gets the most famous
accolades gets the most endorsement
money
their purse is a little different their
personal different i think that's why
francis
is going to obviously decide not to
choose option a choose option b
fight his last fight with sirogon his
team assumes he's gonna win um
again when we get close to the fire
we'll break that down i i definitely
think france has a great shot to break
it down uh to win that fight definitely
his toughest fight by far in his entire
career stylistically it's a nightmare
for him but he can't get it done and
i'll tell you how he gets it done but um
they assume he's going to win
and then hit the free market
now they're business plan is when he
hits the free market
i'm assuming they don't really care
about his mma career after that
he could go to bellator go to ryzen or
one championship or you know pfl or
something like that or bare knuckle
forgot i don't know who the [ __ ] sign up
to fight france to bear knuckle but
there's some dummies out there
but once you're out of the ufc that kind
of legacy's over especially in america
and really worldwide unless you're you
know balls deep into horizon and uh you
know the one championship out there and
it's just not the ufc but
he's not chasing that what his team
wants is when he leaves they're chasing
a tyson fury fight a wilder fight and
why would they chase that do they think
he's going to win they might
they might um and he has the power where
if he were to catch one of those guys he
could possibly knock them out but he i
would assume he's a
six to ten to one underdog especially
against tyson i would assume he's a four
to five to 100 against wilder that's
being nice here
so obviously the odds are against him to
win those fights
i don't think they care about that they
care about that 30 to 40 million payday
and that's what they're chasing that's
what they're banking on
i think it's scary to bank on that
unless again i'll have to talk to markel
when i get out of here unless they have
a confirmation from wilder joshua or
fury goes yeah if you have a ufc
contract we guarantee we'll we will
fight you
i haven't heard anything but guarantee
it's a big risk man it's a big risk
now also with turning it down
and he just beat sarah gone maybe the
ufc goes okay these numbers were
fantastic the pavery numbers are huge
maybe you do deserve more um but from my
understanding you know this francine
and jon jones fight that we've all lust
over and that we all
are dying to see it's my number one
fight i want to see in the ufc
um
that didn't happen because of francis's
team that's what i heard and obviously
john had his issues outside but take
that away
john was willing to fight francis for
the heavyweight title last year but
francis was in negotiations with the ufc
so that's why he didn't get the fight i
think the way the media paints the
picture
is that jon jones want to put on weight
take a year off and do all that [ __ ] and
uh he turned on the fight according to
my sources it was francis who was
waiting to get a bigger deal in order to
fight john he wanted to be paid his
worth and ufc didn't think he was worth
that
so
um you know if you're francis you know
you have option uh a where you resign
with the ufc you win this fight and they
pay you a significantly amount
more that probably not what you're
hoping for but at least more money than
what you've been getting paid or b you
turn down that
offer and you go test the free agency
and you sign a deal with bellator or
ryzen or one championship or pfl or bare
knuckle or something like that and you
have a stipulation of contract where you
can fight tyson fury and wilder and
joshua and you know one of those fights
will pay you more than
any organization in the world and mma
could possibly pay you win lose or draw
you're going to get paid and not only
you can get paid
you know it's a big risk especially if
you can get it done only you get paid
but you get paid twice because no one's
going to sign a one-fight deal to fight
francis there's going to be a rematch
clause in there at some point because
if francis were to
again he hits harder than
than anybody not named deontay wilder
because if francis were able to land one
which he definitely is capable of he
would knock you those men out
i mean either well really into the three
out joshua especially wilder or fury i
think if he were to land flush could
knock them out they're not gonna let him
just right off in the sunset there's
gonna be a rematch so
you know you're looking let's say let's
say let's be conservative you're looking
at at least a let's say 10 million which
would be a low payday for him to fight
one of those guys could be a massive
[ __ ] fight especially if he knocks
out cyril gone for him to fight tyson
fury or deontay wilder anthony joshua
let's say they pay him 10 million that's
still more money in one night of boxing
than he's made his entire ufc career
and if you remember when i did a hot
boxing with mike tyson and francis
tyson kept saying man you hire your own
lawyer you have your own lawyer you
[ __ ] manage you you just need a
lawyer and france like dude i don't make
your money i'm not rich dude you keep
saying hire your own lawyer you know
those guys don't work for free you say i
don't have that money mike's like you
what he's like that's the problem it's
like yeah no [ __ ] dude but a guy like
france who's the champion of the world
he's not gonna hire some big time lawyer
and put him on a [ __ ] retaining fee
and paying that every month he's just
not he doesn't make that type of money
mike tyson who's making 20 to 60 million
dollars a fight can afford to do that
that guy's going to negotiate it and
when you're mike tyson a scarce man on
earth at the time and you know the
fights we knew what were going to happen
you can have just a lawyer francis isn't
there yet man so and he kept
kept saying that i don't
well i'm not making the type of money
you are dude i'm not making that money
and kept saying tyson kept doubling down
on it i was like mike you understand
dude this is the ufc i know he's a
heavyweight champ but he's making a
fraction of what you made dude it makes
no sense please stop saying that but he
just kept doubling down because mike
tyson so that worked out well
um
so yeah i think for francis i appreciate
uh
him taking matters in his own hands
um
but but i i do think uh ufc guys and
we're gonna get to jake paul calling out
dana white and their beef i i do think
these ufc guys
are becoming a little more aware of what
boxers are making guys like jake paul
are making
and it's creating resentment for big
names in the ufc because they're like
hold up dude i am 10 times the [ __ ]
far that kid is he's making how much and
so these guys are willing to to kind of
battle the ufc
now at some point somebody's going to
win it could be francis i don't know
i can't recall anybody as of late
winning a war with the ufc it usually
never goes good
good thing is france is such a beast and
uh athletically gifted where it's not
like you know do you remember the best
cases remember roger wuerta where roger
huerta is training with him great guy
um
he was the first ufc fighter on sports
illustrated remember there was a cage
and he was like flying kicking the guy
was [ __ ] sick bring that up chin
roger sports illustrated article
and we can use graphics now but baby
um
so remember roger werte had the the
world by the balls in regards to the
mixed martial arts uh sport he had like
that too brutal or the future america's
fastest growing most controversial sport
and one what yeah what that says what
may
2007.
so what that's that's the top or bottom
it's right
below the sports illustrated right there
okay let's see what's that is that a
seven
i can't see let me look at a different
one that's clear it has to be 2007
because i was training with him
not when this came out i probably
trained with him a year or two episode i
i started training with him in 2009
and he was seeing or dating the girl the
redhead from
what was that show asking kutcher was on
the show there you go
2007 may 28 2007.
yeah that's when he fought leonard
garcia that was ufc 68. he had the world
by the balls so he was kind of the first
guy to get that kind of publicity
and yeah he was dating her
he would bring her to the gym and she
was
so good-looking
uh she obviously moved on now and good
for her but um
[Music]
yeah shout out to uh roger wuerta
but remember he got too big for his
britches tried bell in the ufc you
remember what happened to him
they said very cool dude so remember you
were uh main eventing fight nights and
we put you on papers and stuff now what
we're going to do is win a shelfia
because you want to fight out your last
two fights very cool and you're going to
go test the free agency very cool well
that's going to hurt our brand so what
we're going to do
is you're on this rocket ship we're
going to pull the fuel from that you're
not going to get to the big start you're
trying to get to we're going to take all
the jet fuel out of your rocket ship and
we're gonna bench you so
you're not relevant and then when you do
fight we're gonna put you on the prelims
and then we're gonna give you the worst
possible match-up
good luck and it ruined roger huerta
they ruined him
no one really ever heard of him after
that went to bellator [ __ ] i think he
still [ __ ] around one championship king
dudes in the face and stuff but he
shaved his head he got kicked in the
head back like soccer kicked in there
yeah it's it's in the think of woodley i
mean and diaz they kept on the shelves
forever because of their issues i
remember that but here's the thing
the thing that bothers me most about all
this
is francis is what
32 he's in his absolute prime dude
go to francine gato
let's get to age real quick 35
he's 35 even more stressful so he's 35.
go to his fights
so in 2021 he fought once
he's again he's in his prime
in 2020 ready he fought once
and remember this is all when
he starts man hey man i need more money
i need more money he's fighting once
he fought twice in 2019.
he beat curtis blaze kane blast yes god
look at the [ __ ] guys he's beat man
curtis blades kane velasquez junior dos
santos rosen stroke stipe now think
about this
and two you're you're in the business
of paying the bills when you punch guys
in the face that's that's your mo that's
how you make your monthly nut your
yearly income is based off bunch of
other grown men in the face in a steel
cage and the ufc gives you a paycheck
in 2020
he worked for 20 seconds
seconds
20 seconds against rosenstroke
and in
granted a pandemic he worked for
five minutes and 52 seconds
so in two years he's worked barely over
six minutes
that's not a way to get better and
create a legacy
so what happens man and then also
remember is stipe and the and the dc
stuff slow things down if you remember
that
and then remember the brock lesnar stuff
dc was going to fight broad there's like
all that stuff and then steep bay
because it kind of [ __ ] up stipe's
income too man
so he's rolling the dice
he's rolling the frickin dice man and i
hope it works out and i think for him
the home run would be getting the fury
and the wilder and the joshua fights and
hopefully that comes to fruition because
one of those fights will change your
life forever and that's all he's banking
on because listen he fights sarah gone
doesn't change his life forever
he's hoping in negotiations if he fights
john it changes his life forever and
hopefully the ufc pays up but doesn't
sound like they're going to because
again their business model isn't
predicated off superstars anymore it's
just based off of number of fights how
many fights can they provide for espn to
get that yearly nut and they're doing
that whether francis fights stipe fights
ds fights conor fights poor a fights
izzy fights
amanda nunes fights julian pena they
don't give a [ __ ] dude
that's not they they were smart they
went all right these guys got too much
control we got to make it about the ufc
brand just like the nfl does
that have no player in this world
including tom brady is bigger than the
nfl shield nobody no coach is more
famous
also
what's interesting about the ufc
is when you watch a fight
it has to be one of the only sports in
the world where the two guys on the
outside of the cage are the most famous
men in the building
joe rogan and dana white two guys not
getting punched in the face
it's the only sports business model
where the two guys
outside the cage
that aren't competing are more famous
than anybody that enters that octagon
it's crazy right
good for them
it's crazy though no other sports like
that like adam silver is not more famous
than lebron james
roger goodell's not more famous than tom
brady
those guys get booed left and right
dana's not getting booed dude den is on
the full send podcast and you know doing
all this [ __ ]
that's brilliant those those guys yes
surrounded by them they're brilliant man
they keep him current he's on tick tock
dancing and [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
the mlb guy i don't know who the [ __ ] it
is he's not famous
but the ufc owner is super famous he's
marking he's all around you know what
i'm saying and i'm not hating on it good
for him man
good for him
so france's playing a
an interesting game and if you're a fan
of fighters you want him to win the way
he wins is by knocking out sarah gone uh
january 22nd and you'll be watching that
on youtube thick boy channel with chris
distefano crystallia brian shall myself
we're all going to celebrate
and i will say you know i
looking at cyril gone
and the way he moves and stuff like that
and i think a lot of people are putting
too much emphasis on the the
sparring footage that was released i
don't i don't care about any of that i i
don't give a flying [ __ ] about any
sparring footage
if you remember when kumar usman was
gonna fight gilbert burns i had people
from att man just going dude i'm telling
practice gilbert [ __ ] him up
okay that's cool
i don't care man dude you're talking to
quote alan afternoon we're talking about
practice not my practice
because i know i've never seen a single
person [ __ ] up camaro usman when the
lights are hot and the cameras are
rolling not never
not never also never seen anybody
besides a man named stipe [ __ ] up
francis and ganu
i was there in boston live when uh stipe
really went to town now also in that
fight i think it changed stipe's uh
dna
the way he moves the quality of life
forever because the shots he ate
trying to get francis down he ate some
[ __ ] shots i don't think his chin's
ever been the same heat some
[ __ ] shots the best shots and
kept going and mop the floor with with
francis but i think my friend you know
in france at the time
people were very close friends told me
his head got too big he thought he was
on touch both i was going to steamroll
through steep bay
i think dana it might have said this on
record but as he's walking to the
lockdown he told dana to get the private
jet ready
well he's walking to the octagon to
fight stipe and boss goes make sure you
get that private jet gassed up i'm gonna
knock this dude out get jump on that
private jet and dana's like okay steve
is pretty good so i think him going
through that experience has made francis
a way better fighter a way better
fighter more experience and i actually
think that experience is going to pay
off against sarah gone because if you
look at
who's been in bigger fights when it
counts it's not even close
the biggest fight that sarah god has
been is
probably that derek lewis fight
and that was a ufc 265 pay-per-view
that's when that was for intern belt he
looked phenomenal in that fight i'll
give him that but prior to that you're
talking really fight nights
first fight on the pay-per-view you know
junior dos santos he beat older junior
right uh rosen stroke went decision with
volklav decision um so he's beat some
quality guys but i'm talking the lights
are hot all the pressure's on the table
francis has walked through that fire and
passed that test many many of times and
that experience says a lot man because
you you look at uh francis man
so he's been the main event um [ __ ] you
look at the main event of
was he the main event against alex
rovery
i don't think so no not ufc 218.
obviously he was the the talk of the
town because that uppercut from [ __ ]
the congo that he [ __ ] bent down and
just upgraded his face off one of the
best knockouts of all time so he just
absolutely destroys astro vrim
gets
pretty beat up by stipe then you get the
derrick lewis fight he learned from that
one
curtis blaze he smokes in 45 seconds
king velazquez he absolutely smokes in
26 seconds
but again
he's the main event
for blades in ghana uh he's the main
event for in ghana cain vasquez he's the
main event for ingano dos santos he's
the main event and then uh you'll see
249 uh francis versus rosenstrike he's
the big boy there 20 seconds
and then obviously
fighting
arguably the best heavyweight of all
time stipe he ko's him in the second
round
um when you're the main event it's just
a different type of pressure and i
usually side with guy with experience
and who's battle tested
and
when you look at their power
francis if this is a video game is a 10
saragon is about a seven now if you hit
your flash he's a heavyweights big
athlete guys quick he's gonna knock you
out
but i would be willing to bet
francis can make some mistakes get hit
go i'm not gonna do that again and the
fight continues
cyril gone can make no mistakes
for 25 minutes inside that gun if
francis lands one
single punch that fight is over and
that's scary that's very scary
so
uh i'm rooting for francis i think it's
a a nightmare of a match up for him but
i like that
cyril god has been there for 25 minutes
with the
arguably the hardest hitter of all time
in the ufc
and i i don't know what the odds are but
i will give my official prediction the
week of the fight
probably on the shop shorts
where that's just more content where
seven eight minute video breaking down
the specific fight i would assume uh
sarah gone is a slight favorite maybe
minus 120 favorite for
in gano's minus 120 yeah
that's super close odds though
damn near even money for mma fight
that's even and that's comple i'm
completely fine with that
he opened it as a minus 190 but
that's even money
great fight
yep
yeah i i don't care about that uh
training footage i just don't
because you have no idea like we don't
know if before that francis
was doing the shark tank rounds where
those of you that not familiar with
shark tank shark tank is
um francis let's say would stay inside
the octagon
during training and a fresh guy would
come in every five minutes while francis
stays in his tire so did francis run
sprints before that did he
you know did he do a shark tank where
he's exhausted and sargon's fresh
because he's the new kid on the block
comes in they don't know how good he is
is i get a lot of questions so i never
put too much in that training footage
never never never never
even when we had a homeboy on
uh from brazil
what's his uh vicente luke we had
vicente lucay and he goes yeah uh camaro
beat my ass in training but anyone
really knows training really doesn't
matter unless
you're a grappler let's say you're a
grappler and your takedown is your thing
and you predicate yourself on getting
takedowns
and you use your best takedown and that
guy you can't get the guy down that is
when it will [ __ ] with you you're like
[ __ ] i can't get him down can't he's
seen it i've given my best shot i can't
get him down if you're a grappler and
that you're only like that's your bread
and butter and you know the guys take
down defense really get good that will
[ __ ] with you but this training footage
that does nothing for francis nothing
nothing at all
it's bit [ __ ] to release it i'm curious
who released it
unwritten rule right well it's probably
written they talk about all the time not
to release footage yeah spark footage
so draftking shows francis at minus
minus 105 and zero is a minus 150. and
that's all we care about yeah
that's interesting
jack hermeson sean strickland i can't
wait for my boy sean strickland get back
in there crazy dude we gotta get sean
strickland on food truck casey
we got our
first food truck on thick boy is it next
week
we shoot on the 14th we shoot on the
14th
big guest
i'll wait till the week up but yeah big
guess with that one that's kind of
all right jim what do you got oh real
quick when you were talking about
um
francis i remember woodley remember when
when he was on top of the world and he
was always back and forth with dana in
the fc and then later on he was saying
if there's one thing i regret doing that
yeah because it wasted so much time and
energy so much energy and time and all
the headlines the headlines aren't about
you beating guys up and your next
matchup the headline is you versus the
ufc and then you can get some support
but eventually if that's just the
narrative over and over friends like
come on dude gennady fans listen this
shows you make
fifty thousand dollars to fight they're
like dude shut the [ __ ] up you have 50
grand that's a ton of money it's like
it's not though for those guys for in
the grand scheme of things
all right
all right so the rumors are this is a
reporter or writer for bjpen.com he said
that the tyron woodley jake paul two
fight
boxing match only generated 65 000
pay-per-view buys terrestrial which
means just tv
not including streaming
yeah i don't know what to make of this
because if
you know i think that guy works for
duzone who released that yeah yeah
he worked for dazn so it's a competing
kind of outlet
um you know the zone doesn't get [ __ ]
out for how long and then they're going
to get these numbers before
you know show time
um
and also terrestrial so like i bought on
my phone so i'm sure it's not counting
no that's streaming you think of the
jake paul fans how many are sitting down
at a tv and watching it
um
so scroll down
uh so this guy at uh stephen mulhausen
at s mullenhausen jr
um
someone said completely believable add
on digital buy as you're looking at
around 100k the act is wearing thin
which is why he's begging for ufc for
access to the stars they invested 10
million to cultivate
this is the app fight oracle so this guy
put this is a fair argument only other
things that come to mind are one no one
wanted to see a rematch i agree with
that two that was the sixth combat sport
pay-per-view in six weeks agree
or you know money's tough
um they're four bucks and two ufc i
don't think boxing really affects that
though to be honest
um
and it would and it is overpriced
so there's some argument there but um
the six pay-per-views in six weeks
the boxing ones doesn't affect this i i
you know the the mma community is not
really paying for those boxing ones
the jake paul fans sure is [ __ ]
paying for those boxing ones
i just but i also think
you know them saying that the low
numbers is the way he can attack jake
because how else can you attack him he's
knocking these guys out
he's taken the world by the balls he's
kind of the the cheat code in this old
old business model of boxing and he's
put it on its head
so it's the popular thing to do to say
oh it's getting low it's not he's not
doing well you got to be careful with
that stuff so when i saw that i was like
65 seems pretty low
if it's just tv i can kind of believe it
because i think
i would just so that so the guy below
him put
the fight oracle goes you know with
non-terrestrial tv numbers you're
looking over 100k
you know i i think it's more than 120 to
000 buys which still isn't great
because what the last one do what'd the
first one do jake's over 500 000.
i think there's something to be said
that
you know i i wasn't too excited about
this rematch
you know what dude so real quick just a
correction so that yeah you're right
it's the zone writer i mixed it up with
the bjpen.com no he's a straight to zone
yeah so you're talking about a
competitive
streaming service sitting on another one
yeah and also i read something on mma
fighting where
they also have sources and they're
saying it's it's supposed to be way more
than that so something's off i would go
more
towards mma fighting yeah of course
because i don't i've never heard of this
guy and he works for de zone writer for
design yeah and to zone you know what
you don't talk about uh the titanic of
fight leagues when we talk about cracked
ship
when it comes to fighting i think they
have their hand in the
battles
and this is jaker
so jake put the paper number rumors are
complete [ __ ] i said complete but he
says rumors are [ __ ] first fight
with wooly we sold 500k plus
numbers for this one are still rolling
in but look still looking positive not
my best business night but remember
everyone wanted to see me versus fury
and that's what we sold shout out to
showtime for ryan with me and all the
fires on the card and for woodley for
not being a [ __ ] like most of these
fighters are
and there's mma fighting coming from a
split decision uh okay
yeah yeah i i'm not buying the 65 000
just not in any fast
that's just that's insanely low from 565
and then they're like yeah because the
there's so many boxing pay-per-views
it's like
no one's watching that dude
and chill son said something on a i
don't know if there's a podcast but he
said something like
one of the reasons he think it could be
is because the first fight was on a
sunday and this was on a saturday
so people thought i was gonna be on a
sunday some something like that no these
are guys just i mean literally it's a
cool thing to do to [ __ ] on jake paul
and i get it i completely get it i'm not
buying 65 000.
no
at all
i bet i i bet it was around
high hundreds probably i bet after i'll
send in 200 yeah i'll be fair hundred
two hundred sounds more right at least a
hundred at least
100 i would bet my last dollar he did
over a hundred
alrighty well
you know about this already but dana
watt and jake paul have been going back
and forth issuing challenges to each
other and dana white started with this
one because apparently yeah we're going
to start dana calling him out he called
him out because jake paul says that dana
white does cocaine okay all right so
then dana white responded with this and
did he tweet this out or he put a video
out
um
[Music]
i think it was
instagram okay so dan put i got
challenge for jake paul this guy keeps
saying that i'm a coke head he can
randomly cocaine test me for the next 10
years if i can randomly steroid test him
for the next two ten versus two
yeah
and jake didn't really respond to that
challenge he just gave him another
challenge
but happy new year dana white here's a
real challenge for you i will
immediately retire from boxing fight
horry mazda on the ufc if you agree to
increase the minimum pay fighter to 50k
it's 12k right now guarantee ufc 50 of
ufc annual revenues 1 billion 2021 the
best year ever provide long-term health
care to all fighters you prove he said
brain damage is part of the gig imagine
the nfl said that there are many ufc
alums who have probably said they are
suffering from brain damage facts
you have five days to accept and to
implement the above by march 31st once
implemented i will immediately retire
from boxing enter usa usada and agree to
a one-fight deal with the ufc and fight
weak chin george to all you see fighters
time to take a stand and create value
for yourselves and peers you deserve
higher paid deserve long-term health
care and above all you deserve freedom
support each other i'm not your enemy
i'm your advocate who sells she wants to
kill a few of you to make some big bank
fair point
um and then there's videos right yeah so
dana white
i'll just play this entire video it's
not that long
jake you never responded to the
challenge
you publicly stated that i use cocaine i
do not
so i told you you could randomly cocaine
test me for the next 10 years yeah i
don't think danny's gonna i believe that
you're a cheater and i believe that you
use steroids
so i want to randomly steroid test you
for the next two years
and that thing that you came out with
today
nobody on earth thinks that you really
wrote that you're too stupid
and for those of you that don't know if
you've ever watched one of his fights
and you see when they do the stare down
the guy that's standing in the middle
with the warlock nose and the big
warlock ward on his face
apparently that's his manager and that
guy used to be an accountant for me
and
let's just say this he no longer works
for me and i think he's a scumbag
but
if you two think that you can do it
better than we do uh you know
we're doing this whole thing wrong you
could treat the fighters better than we
do knock yourself out go start your own
business it's easy to do goes to get the
warlock on it the warlock can get it
started for you
what you and the warlock should be
focused on is your business
your tanking you can't sell
pay-per-views you know no yeah you're
calling out jorge masvidal because he's
a pay-per-view superstar
nate diaz
conor mcgregor mike tyson
these are all superstars
you're not you can't sell pay-per-view
so
you do whatever the hell you want to do
i'm ready to roll buddy i don't use
cocaine do you use steroids
let's do this jake
g let me see jake's
i mean
hold on there's a bunch of stuff here so
do we have the jake video though we have
some of y'all it's probably on his
instagram i have it here let me see let
me see his instagram
i don't know like a straight up video
with like edits and [ __ ]
hold on let me load this again
it's a prince truck
i think chris is the first one to do
that
so there's a part one and a part two
let's do part one first
my my response to daniel it's
embarrassing response
never responded to the
challenge dana i accepted every part of
your challenge i said i would fight
myself in mma steroid tests me whenever
the [ __ ] you want it is two weeks after
my fight and i am a fat [ __ ] i don't do
steroids and i take it as a compliment
because there's no other excuse to me
knocking out all of your champions then
this kid does steroids look at me
a fat [ __ ] if you steroid test me then
i want to steroid test every one of your
fighters
i use cocaine i'm in st parks one of the
nicest beaches in the world you're
ruining my vacation we were on a yacht
party last night meek mill drake
everybody mike tyson going crazy you
have been caught with cocaine and
hookers every other week i use cocaine
and you think that like with all the
money that you have like billionaire or
some [ __ ] that you would get some
[ __ ] botox because your forehead
looks like a [ __ ] gps google
map like all the lines in it and [ __ ]
i use cocaine and you say mozzarella is
a pay-per-view superstar let's go to his
last instagram post 5 000 likes or 10
000 likes or some [ __ ] do you realize
that my mom pam gets more likes
pay-per-view superstars men lie women
lie dana white lies numbers don't you
want to talk [ __ ] about my manager who
is the cfo of your company that helped
you sell it to endeavour four billion
dollars guy that's standing in the
middle apparently that's his manager and
that guy used to be an accountant for me
you're just a jealous ugly [ __ ] you
don't know what true happiness is you're
the definition of a [ __ ] unhappy
billionaires who thought that money was
going to make their lives better feel
bad for you i used cocaine long story
short you addressed nothing that i said
i accepted your challenge i said i would
fight mma i said that i would retire
from boxing and you avoided all of that
[ __ ] hold on also instant replay there
was a [ __ ] ufo in the back of this
video simon
joe rogan aliens we're all [ __ ] it
shows that you are in a corner you're a
dog in a corner trying to fight to save
this whole company and the embarrassment
that i've put you through everybody sees
it and what you can't accept or love or
appreciate is that i'm trying to change
the sport forever and you are one of the
most selfish captain
part two
oh there oh yeah 40 seconds
are one of the most selfish capitalistic
[ __ ] that i've ever seen and
everybody else needs you dana i'm the
only person that doesn't need you and i
don't give a [ __ ] about you but all
these people all your fighters all of
them they can't say [ __ ] cause you'll
just bench them you met your maker i'm
not gonna stop welcome to the show
ladies and gentlemen i use cocaine the
bottom line dana is that you won't add
health care for your fighters because
you don't give a [ __ ] about them and
you're too much of a greedy [ __ ] to pay
your minimum fighter more than twelve
thousand dollars for risking their lives
it's what a janitor makes you need to
pay them fifty thousand dollars dana
stop avoiding my points oh one of the
most
oh man so this is what happens when how
old's damn damn near 60. let's be in the
50s what
would you be 50 something right i'm
saying maybe early 50s or late 40s i'm
saying it has to be 50. let's see
51 52. so davis fit so this is what
happens when a 52 year old
decides to attack
uh and go at a guy in jake paul who
literally
has
the youtube social media world by the
[ __ ] balls so dana's video dana's
video is it's like you know if my dad
facetime they're like i don't need to
see up your nose so it's like a bad
lighting he's clearly like in his
mansion whatever it's just bad lighting
it he and he doesn't address anything
that jake asks for right so it's like
he's kind of rambling a little bit
and then jake goes he's off seeing saint
barts of partying for new year's and
someone tells him dana [ __ ] is what he
ha he shoots this video sends it to his
team who all they do is make content and
cut and create
and literally just
directs dana white in this because he's
using graphics and references and edits
him saying i use cocaine it's like this
is a 10-6 round for jake paul man easily
easily so for dana white it doesn't do
any justice it again again
dana's the most famous person in the ufc
because he does this stuff and he
actually enjoys it and which is fine i
have no issue with that
but it's like if you're gonna jump in
this pool
have the team ready to go because you
know you're [ __ ] with these
millennials man like when even fighters
these younger friends when they talk
[ __ ] it's so ugly man there's like they
pull no cards there's no
the rules of baseball the rules of
fighting are out the window with these
young kids man and for jake paul
especially and logan paul
they it's just the the
the markers are off man and they're
willing to go and do whatever it takes
and their team is the best in the world
at editing and doing these things
so you're taking dana who is video
you know a little rambly it's one take
it's the shots from his nose up it's
like a blair witch project type of view
and jake paul's on vacation and spitting
facts and they're throwing up the the
graphics and it's just so much more
produced and his points a lot more
cleaner so it's a 10-6 round for jake
paul if i'm dana this isn't i mean we're
talking about it so i get it but this
isn't the right you wanna do go but also
i think with
dana doing this and him addressing jake
paul it only makes jake paul bigger it
only makes him it's building this
momentum for jake paul so he's playing
to the exact hand that jake paul wants
and is jake paul is he ever gonna get
steroid tested no is dana ever gonna go
okay jake i'll do that and then you test
me for cocaine and i'll pay fighters
more is that ever happening no
but in hindsight there's not one person
that watches jake paul's video and
doesn't go has some points and it's
entertaining and fun
[ __ ] ufo that was good yeah that was
good 10 secs for jake paul
[Music]
yeah this isn't a
you you're playing a game man and you're
you're playing it with the the guys who
have a team who specialize in this you
know like dana's a little bit out of his
lane in this and that that
video can the the difference between
those two videos can show more there to
a 52 year old man trying to compete with
a 20 whatever he is kid and he he was
born on the youtube i was born on the
youtube you know what i'm saying he's
like bane he's born in the youtube born
in the darkness man he's he thrives in
that so dana's jumping to that and
they're editing it and [ __ ] make him
look stupid it's bad angles he's
clowning the
you know the wrinkles in his forehead
google maps
that was a good video yeah 10-6 jake
paul
[Music]
okay just
we'll get off the paul brothers in a sec
but so logan paul says that floyd
mayweather never paid him for the fight
right six months later still hasn't got
paid for the fight weird yeah
um according to daily star floyd miller
and so much from logan paul fight he
could buy jeff bezos jet paul fought
mayweather last year and what could only
be considered a novelty fight
extravaganza
respond
thusly on social media great words
sunday yeah because the dirty little rat
hasn't paid me yet it's been six months
and happy new year to you sir but no
worries floyd miller applauded ksi are
going to make back the money you stole
from me and more january 4th so he just
hasn't paid him that's what he's saying
that's he's claiming and remember i'm
sure he hasn't been paid because he got
paid
yeah but uh floyd also remember when he
first signed this fight he's like i'm
gonna it's like a bank robbery kind of
thing whatever
i don't know how much that you know
that's not good yeah
and that showtime produced it but it was
a uh money mayweather probably a
promotion or whatever so they control
all the the money so that's a bad luck
on floyd's part
yeah you got to pay him for god's sakes
yeah logan paul ksi really i just barely
found that out today so apparently
they're going to announce the fight that
they're doing the third fight on january
4th which is tomorrow
so yeah i don't know another fight i
don't want this i just honestly saying
at least the youtubers want to see it i
don't i don't know
they did enormous i think the first time
or the first and second but i don't know
yeah we'll see
okay this is tony ferguson
saying that he has a fight with chandler
but then uh chandler's uh delaying it
like not signing it or whatever so
chandler was responding to someone else
chandler responded to someone that asked
like if you were gonna fight conor would
you strike or wrestle and he goes out
strike and then ferguson yeah ferguson
wrote this one here's my [ __ ] at mike
chandler mma the brass dane white
relayed your mess saying you would be
ready to fight me in april june looks
like you're trying to delay that [ __ ]
i owe you for cutting in line kid it's
wrestling season [ __ ] man up
champ i would watch the [ __ ] out of that
fight
yeah um it's tough fight for tony
exactly dude that's exactly what i'm
thinking and then did uh yeah oh tony
there's only a handful of guys in this
game i truly respect you're one of them
only because your tenure not your
stature your current presence than
division i'll beat you from bell to bell
pray for
merciful ref we shall see if this fight
happens
i think for chandler right his last
fight was uh
the title fight right yeah i'm blanking
right now to say oliveira he got
drunk
he got dropped but yeah yeah that was a
great fight with justin geisha yeah so
yeah great fight with chandler great
fight with geichi but he's owen too
so i think he wanted to do he was hoping
for a dust and pour a fight but poirier
is trying to get the ds fight
so i think challenge just waiting it out
to see if he gets the pouring fight if
the diaz fight falls out and that's all
he's doing but chandler versus [ __ ]
ferguson sign me up
very tough fight for tony though yeah in
his curtain
seriously that's like probably one of
the worst matches i've imagined tonight
in the office but never know yeah you
never know so speaking of diaz does the
other diaz brother nick diaz dana white
pretty much openly said that he doesn't
think nick even wants to do it it's like
going to work and bumper-to-bumper
traffic he has to do it so that's why
that's a fight yep
yeah so he's saying he shouldn't fight
again yeah the rumor is he he owes
someone money i get he gets dark wow
yeah it's really dark now these are all
rumors of course remembers he did it to
pay something back yeah he doesn't want
to do it but he has to
so regardless of how good he looked our
way did after such a huge layoff i don't
think nick should fight
it's not that i wasn't that i was in
favor of it he's a grown man can do
whatever he wants to do i just don't
think that nick does it because he loves
it i think nick does it because he has
to do it i don't know man people always
ask me what's key to success it's all
about being happy and doing what you
love
and then when i was talking about the
people who sit in bumper bumper traffic
and go to job they hate that's what i
feel like nick diaz when he's getting
ready for a fight
white said he's in bumper to bumper
traffic going to a job that doesn't that
he doesn't love at all it's actually
fascinating but for a guy that's been
off as long he has nothing but respect
for nick i agree with him oh yeah you
kind of have to right he doesn't look
like he ever wants to yeah rumor rumor
is yeah
that's the dark web rumor he he he owes
something always money yep that's that's
hopefully not hopefully he's just doing
it because you want to get back in there
who knows i don't know
yeah and it was weird because he looked
super good remember in his instagram
photos when he was like getting cut up
but then when he showed up for the fight
different yeah what the hell happened i
don't know
yeah it's all it's all fascinating all
right your boy sugar shawn o'malley he
made a video
going to walmart and handing people
hundred dollar bills or a hundred
dollars love sugar shot o'malley
so he was handing out 100 cash to
strangers at walmart for christmas yeah
which is a very nice act you know
that's great man but he's one of his
rivals cheeto
another great guy cheetah marlon vera
he uh
he goes this
you don't need a camera guy i love
cheeto i just don't know i'm yesterday
but you don't need a camera to help you
with your piece of [ __ ] just simple as
that dude
then you scroll down uh-huh but yeah
giving out money some people didn't like
it i said this one guy tweet something
like you give money out you give money
out without you don't need a camera guy
what was it well first of all it's my
sister she's a girl don't be sexist
girls can record videos too no respect
all right
you don't need a camera guy to help
people you piece of [ __ ] i know uh that
to be honest i was actually taken back
by that i thought if i did did without
recording it the people i gave it to
wouldn't care those other people i give
a hundred dollars to
had to have a camera there for them to
care so that was my fault and i actually
learned something today i gave homeless
guy 20 bucks i didn't record it he
didn't care maybe he's onto something
maybe
maybe i'm on to something i don't know i
thought it was pretty fun i enjoyed it i
had a good feeling in my heart giving
money to those people still feel like
you p person even if i'm a piece of [ __ ]
still felt like a good person
yeah dude it's
how you hate on a guy giving that money
to people i mean if you if you want to
film it i mean that's cool i know i
always had a weird feeling about that
but at the end of the day you're helping
people so that's what matters and the
dayless people whether you record not
still got a hundred dollars cash which
for a lot of people is a big deal and
you're also inspiring people to do the
same thing so even though like people
hate on did you give a hundred dollars i
know
if you did then and didn't film it then
you can talk [ __ ] but did you give a
hundred dollars you didn't
yeah yeah it's a weird thing i'm a
little torn but yeah at the end of the
day you're helping people that's what
matters the most yeah
okay so sean o'malley says that
you know connor obviously did the proper
12 that you talked about earlier so he
wants to do the same type of thing with
marijuana which sounds like it's a
perfect match right yeah and take it
from your boy here the the whiskey game
what conor did
he have some smart guys on his team with
the distribution stuff like that and
that's half the battles the distribution
you said it was a beast we adjust for
everything right super beast you go
through all that and then with the laws
and regulations of alcohol getting each
state and you know worldwide it's a it's
a it's a beast man and you know i don't
i don't have the connection to get done
so uh thank god the team that i have and
conor has a very smart team around him
who got that done
now we talk about
marijuana same thing you're talking
about federal laws you talking about
marijuana it's legal in some states not
living in other states so you have to
get with the right business partner um
i do think that could be a huge business
for sugar shawn i can't believe someone
hasn't come to the diaz brothers and
created diaz brothers straight they do a
cbd i think but i don't know about
strangers i'm talking straight up mike
tyson farm style
because if the diaz and sugar shawn got
together they could do something
yeah yeah
and i don't know anybody who wouldn't
take them on
and i'm sure you i'm sure we all know
people that have been in the weed game
like the ones i know of they're so
freaking rich like so they're rich and
most of them are they're not like you
would think
you know i don't know what you guys
think when we think of marijuana but
it's not like there are these potheads
no no the people i know make bank and
marijuana like straight businessmen and
it's no different than
you know hustling [ __ ] painkillers or
t-shirts or shoes or they're just
businessmen they see the upside to it
and they get invested and when you get a
business guys of sharks they have the
connections to do it worldwide and
that that's when you're you know selling
for a hundred million dollars yeah and
also weed is not like you know
painkillers are terrible but wheat is
actually good you know for a lot of
people it's really good people use it
and it's sanctioned in a lot of states
yep
but yeah when you get an alcohol
salesman
you're talking about this headache
getting the texas alcohol commission to
florida to new york to california
california's the toughest but it's my
home state compared to denver compared
to montana it's just it was different
but it's a dope whiskey and that's like
one of the coolest freaking labels yeah
it's pretty cool it's gonna yeah it's
always not the best looking i honestly
think come on
uh real quick one about sean o'malley as
well cody garbrandt says that
he'd want him to be his next fight
even though he won't move down to 125 he
said he's next fight you want he'll go
back to one thing that's why i said
after cody
lost you know which was heartbreaking
yeah you know now
more so than ever it makes the most
sense for each guy yeah for sugar shawn
who you know he has a one loss cheeto
but coming off two big victories um for
cody garbrandt obviously has fallen on
tough times it's still former champs
still a big name
everyone say cody hasn't fought anybody
or say sugar shawn hasn't fought anybody
cody garbrandt still ranked i think top
ten makes a lot of sense
yeah it's a great fight
top five for both guys i think
that's a tough fight yeah yeah
okay we were just talking about sean
strickland he said something else crazy
as per usual
he said if he had a gay son then he has
failed as a man but then he's responding
to someone on twitter
so this guy asked this sean would you
have a gay son or a thot daughter he put
if i had a gay son i would think i
failed his man to create such weakness
about a [ __ ] for her daughter i think
she just wanted to be like her dad
he's being funny he's being funny he's
been funny then obviously they're going
to run with it and then he did this gay
men are great to support them in their
choice freedom gays have made it most
gays i know are always happy they all
just get to hang with buddies all day
and have sex so straight man we're
[ __ ] we gotta do something serious
work to get laid not fair yeah i agree
that's part of my bit man how much
easier my life would be if i just gave
[ __ ] um
yeah i think sean's being funny there
that's all that is yeah i won't break it
down too he's just being funny though
exactly if he just tweeted that out just
this is how i feel no one asked him a
question it'd be a little different yeah
it'll be tough
all righty um oh this is another crazy
one so this guy used to find the ufc he
was jory payne
or anyways he's fine efc and he said the
way that he got his money to start
martial arts
is by doing sex work in japan with
another dude like had to jack him off
damn he was just like there's other ways
to make money and plus he just he has
like 14 something thousand followers he
just
he's just being honest he's opened up
about it on what huh on instagram on his
twitter
um japanese star 26 jesse was talk
talked in a painful experience by a
friend five years ago keeps going down
at just21 the budding martial artist
claimed he went through uh
with the act to earn 130 pounds
more than he would have pocket in two
days at his part-time job to help
kick-start his career i mean how bad you
want it man
uh sharing the story with his 14 000
twitter follows
he claims five years ago when i was with
a friend i was told that i could get
money for a sex act in shaibua shibuya
shibuya
i followed him i was told to hide my
face i was deceived in various ways i'd
have the money and really wanted to do
martial arts on my own
um he got twenty thousand or yeah 130
pounds in less than an hour
i was able to start martial arts for
short time and see the amount of two
days part-time work that i do for eight
hours while standing
uh nicknamed the rising star called the
experience painful but was happy to be
able to chase his dreams continue it's
pretty painful now but as long as i'm
alive i can chase my dreams and i like
women dude but i like women
i've earned the money to live to do
martial arts he's eight and two five kos
he lost his last fight oh that wasn't 20
years he won the last three fights and
rise including a victory over nakata
last month good for him yeah so i mean
just opened up about it yeah i mean i do
i just wanted to [ __ ] fight
now we sure was just to jack the guy off
that's who said that i i heard it
somewhere someone wrote an article and
said he was just
i don't know if someone's saying that
much just for a hand job that's 130 130
pounds i don't know how much that is i
think that's almost 300 right let's see
175 i'm sorry i'm talking about united
yeah dude i don't think because he could
just go to a bath house or he could go
to
any massage parlor in [ __ ]
china and get jacked up for 30 bucks
i don't know
but i mean
he's just being open that's interesting
that he even
so it's a 146 bucks yeah well that's if
that's if it's euros i'm not sure it
pounds euros or no
but uh anyways okay so speaking of money
mark hunt this is on bg but i think
that's where i got mixed up so again
another guy who went to battle with the
ufc yes and still in the title the
reason the ufc is so powerful that the
best lawyers in the goddamn game those
ufc contracts are [ __ ] airtight yeah
there's no hiccups in them there's
nothing like that they know exactly what
they're doing
yeah so hunt says marcon ordered to pay
the ufc over 375k in legal fees and
they're going to come after you man
so hunt fought a lawsuit in the ufc
shortly following his fight with brock
lesnar at uc 200 the super simone
claimed that the promotion put in the
cage with a fighter who he says the ufc
knew was using pd's brock lesnar her
case was originally dismissed 2019
however the appeals court decided to
reopen the case on fraud and battery
september 2021
mark hunt addressed his small victory by
suggest that some justice has been
served
uh this is mark hunter he said you
[ __ ] said to me many moons ago if i
was a gambling man and i will ask you
here the same question because you ain't
ever going to get rid of me i'm a
[ __ ] gangster i got the rusty
fork waiting for all you [ __ ] ass
eyeballs damn white you better kill me
brah you ain't going anywhere g you and
your little [ __ ] friends you [ __ ]
have stolen from so many of us fighters
in our families finally just about to be
start for you punk [ __ ] enjoy
it [ __ ] all those who scoffed and
laughed at me said all sorts of [ __ ] you
all can kiss my black
ass you filthy coward [ __ ]
oh yeah so then afterwards he was
apparently this is according to
bjpenn.com uh they said that he had or
he was ordered but unfortunately for
hunt his small victory against dana
white and ufc was short-lived as per
recent report from combat sports law the
knockout artist has been ordered to pay
the ufc over 375k in legal fees
[Music]
and that's that's i guess the order it's
actually 388
[Music]
mm-hmm
that's
not funny so mark hunt like even said
something about bjp.com saying like you
know where'd you guys get your
information it's not that's not true but
i guess because he's filing appeals so
it's not like you know 100 percent he's
not yeah yeah all right and then
he wanted to do this
he wrote this right here
mark this oh man
all right mark the super simone versus
dana the parasite white lorenzo team
frank fertitta
five rounds i'm ready these losers dan
white frankfurt uh lorenzo has sucked
the life out of so many fighters him and
his scum friends you win i dropped the
lawsuit i win you pay every friday have
ripped off since ufc started now who
would pay to see that
that's not happening i know fun fun post
though
yeah
all right um here's a quick update not
much information but a quick update on
anthony johnson and bellator
so he's still dealing with his medical
issue
i mean i'm sure you heard rumblings
about what
i talked to anthony johnson about it
yeah so
at this point they don't know when he's
going to come back but he's like you
know we'll talk as soon as your health
is better yeah it's amazing major health
yeah major major hopefully he's okay
definitely
all right so this happened over the
weekend tension nasukawa and
hakunorigomi apparently ended in a draw
i didn't watch it but it didn't draw and
also over the weekend was this this is
actually pretty popular fury pro
grappling three but a lot of you had to
pull out rose rose and then the reason
why she pulled out all that says is like
uh coveted protocols so i don't know if
she was around someone without something
the covid i don't know but uh the cove
could potentially
unless carlos she actually opened up her
eye too damn it yeah yeah kelly jesus
christ she's she's very pretty yeah damn
sean brady beat craig jones that was
like a huge upset yeah it's huge
and then donald trump got uh rear naked
choked yeah so that's tough one
billy quantino decision though beat
chase hooper that's a shame
and then neil magni got bt oh neil magni
guillotine wow
alex caceres damn this is cool yeah a
lot of like that's really cool yeah
that's sick
it's pretty cool and then so there's
some footage of this
this reminded me of your thing with the
[Music]
cyborg let me see if i can find it let's
see here so apparently he was super
entertaining kevin holland as per usual
that makes sense so i'll play this one
all right halfway through our final
prelim don't forget to be signed up over
at ufc fight pass always grab the neck
as he drives out
[Applause]
paulie trying to get a little squeeze at
the edge here before they fall off the
same we should just leave it like a
street fight let them fight onto the
table out into the crown how fun would
that be well we are in the former ecw
arena paul felder
many a street fighter and paul felder
was the analyst wow
ufc let all the boys do it weapon night
years back yeah that didn't end well i
think that was that was probably more
czw
interesting that's what reminded me of
your oh
yeah that's cool man pretty cool for
sure
cyborg is in a bit of trouble now he's
not doing well oh wow that sucks we
won't get into it but he's not doing
well there's carlos well she's not
fighting for a towel anytime soon mm-hmm
that is pretty deep dude yeah so
accidentally scar tissue she's all
whoops what she's all i know
yeah that sucks dude
okay so a couple of fight announcements
kaika france who just beat cody oh he's
fighting asgard that's great
great fight
and then we have
marlon rise versus song
you're our favorites dude who's really
really good
and
you like this one
no i'm not mad at that
yeah
and
well
scott coker is targeting he wants
because cats and god has been calling
out cyborg for a while now so he's like
that's most likely gonna be the next
fight right yep
and then this one here
so i wasn't that familiar with uh
jaroslav amazoff but he's a killer and
that's the one that they're trying to uh
put up against michael venomotion att
guy yeah check out his record yeah he's
a [ __ ] monster 26 and no yeah so you
just beat douglas yep lima too wow
yeah so that's a huge fight for
the venom page
what would be for the title yeah
he's 26-0 2016. jesus christ
yeah
that's tough
good amount of submissions too
he seems like a well-runner dude yeah
[ __ ] yeah man that's a tough night in
the office for sure
okay so i don't remember this because we
had the headphones off i think this is
the one so michael bisming was
interviewing ricky simone and then i
guess after he won that fight against
hoffel at sunsell
michael brisbane said something like oh
that's your you beat your first ranked
opponent and then ricky simone corrected
him like no i've beaten a ranked guy
before yeah and bisping didn't really
like that because i guess he thought he
was making him trying to look stupid or
whatever on on
but also there's producers in there so
many of the producers yeah so that's
exactly what disney said he said the
producers when i told him that yeah
there you go
bison was asked where he secured it on
his youtube page he goes i've beaten
ranked before but he said i said well
you definitely weren't ranked because he
he wasn't ranked he's trying to make me
look silly i'm literally relaying the
information i was told to say by the
producer yep so how you direct your vet
at him i tell him not to be such a
little [ __ ]
maybe he didn't want to be corrected
simone simon told mma fight i mean is
there a rule that i'm not allowed to
correct him on here or something oh if
there is maybe i should have said
something after but this is my life
that's why i put everything into i do
all right
and i've i have the receipts i found a
ranked guy before i be beat a ranked guy
i was ranked before i just thought i
would clear that up yeah he's just like
no ill he didn't know why this being's
upset about it it's kind of like yeah
bismillah shouldn't be upset no it's
actually it's not biz being it's the
producer yeah yes but the the producer
is the one
yeah feeding it oh yeah yeah tell them
what's going on yeah yeah anyways that
was a quick one
this is a very sad one bj penn's father
passed away
jd pen that's tough for bj man i guess
he was dealing with parkinson's
that's a shame and then like literally
almost all the like the big mma stars
you know showed love yeah it's a
pleasure
thanks for giving me the greatest life
i've ever had always hugging me and
making me breakfast jesus christ
shout out to bj and his dad man yep is
his dad white
that's the thing i discovered about this
post too i thought he had two hawaiian
like straight-up hawaiian parents but i
guess he's white well that's cool he
looks white at least that's cool yeah
that's cool
okay legend that's a tough pose for him
i bet i know poor bj we'll lighten it up
right now bj's running for governor two
of hawaii he was tr yeah he's definitely
trying he still is yeah uh your boy roy
mcdonald
he i follow him on instagram and he
posts like him working out but check out
his gym
interesting right it's so small
yeah it'd be tough to move in there
i mean it's really really small but yeah
that's his gym i just thought that was
interesting
well it's a home gym and his kiddos
doing it
that's cute is jammy say time to
hibernet hybrid
time to hibernate shows a little cute
bear on there yeah kids are cute as [ __ ]
man
he has a very adorable family
[Music]
what's he have too
yeah i think he has like daughter and i
think you just do i mean his family it
looks like a there yeah it's like a yes
always like a portrait a beautiful
portrait yeah goddamn they look good
yeah is that cowboy hat on too
you know
just wife's a diamond his your wife is
so beautiful man yeah it's rory mcdonald
you know
um let's see i think that's
i think that's it dude is that it yeah
all right man fun show first one in the
books really
is it's
we said yeah 267 as of today but then
there's more yeah there's more but first
one on our own with the thick boy
production crew here chin and casey and
mike and the whole squad getting
together
um shout out to florida had a great time
bringing the new years in dania florida
great club um
two shows coming up this week
la this freaking wednesday wednesday
night one show only very very special
guest
one of the funniest people that is in my
life will be making a special guest
appearance wednesday night one show only
the others we have sam tripley brian
callan chappelle lacy eric griffin huge
special guest and myself one night one
show 8 p.m hollywood improv los angeles
california right off melrose right there
one show only those tickets will sell
out so get them right now and then also
this week thursday starting thursday
rally north carolina is january 6
through january 8th that's this thursday
friday saturday in raleigh north
carolina get your tickets at fatkz.com
like and subscribe to the thick boy
youtube if you're enjoying this show
and your rss audio feeds stay exactly
the same thank you for riding with your
thick friend thank you for watching this
on the thick boy youtube then also like
i told you we launched the super cast
you can get every show that i do ad free
we got two different tiers the first
year you get the shop show food truck
calabasas fight companion you get amas
you get the classic fight companions
where i'm gonna watch my old school ufc
fights the connor fights izzy fights
rhonda fights brock lesnar fights you
get a special cowbes
classic fight companion ad free as well
on there the second tier you get all
that plus firing the kid twice a week ad
free video audio go sign up for super
cash right now to get every single thing
that i do ad free appreciate you guys
stay thick stay safe like subscribe go
to the super cats right now see you next
week